hey everybody I'm Scott Butterworth here
to bring you some reactions from
PlayStation meeting which happens just
earlier today one of the biggest things
to come out of that event we actually
got some new footage of Mass Effect
Andromeda which is like a rare thing
it's taken a very long time to actually
see this game in action so i'm joined by
rob handlery and jake deckard to talk a
little bit about what we actually saw
today so hey guys hey doing good doing
good how are you are you excited about
what we just saw like how'd overall what
are your reactions to the the demo that
we just got earlier today so I am so
excited to finally see Mass Effect stuff
but yeah there's a but it was not very
interesting or exciting like there were
a couple things you could pick out they
were kind of cool and then they had the
end which was kind of explosive but
there was no like you know really seeing
the combat I'm I was waiting for like an
end shot where like writer the
character's name would get in a ship and
take off and like actually piloted or
something cuz that's right word but it
turns out you just walk you just walked
through a cave a little bit yeah rub how
do you feel yeah it was a weird slice
and by slice like the thinnest sliced
you know even out road yeah on that like
a van okay like I'm you know yeah
exactly you want to see a little more um
it looked really good yeah it's all um
the gym the 4k the slick PlayStation pro
4k look pretty good um I mean I think
notably what for a game i think you know
they've been kind of like selling this
game as a more exploration heavy Bay
exploration based game and you kind of
got got the little sense of the no man's
sky scanning a plan and like reading
yeah like yeah you know I guess you can
imagine you know that there'll be some
kind of achievement or some experience i
guess you can get out of that stuff
you're going to new plan and you're
exploring very much so uh but yeah no
you know no action no like women you
Serena they did tease like they were
showing that sort of universe map with a
bunch of like glowing planets and
talking about all the vaults and how
they're not active apparently this is
going to be like the next Borderlands
game I guess first thing I yeah right i
mean vaults in the context of video
games like it's really hard for me to
not go Oh Borderlands but yeah it is
sort of indicating there's going to be
more exploration that this is like a big
universe driven game but yeah in terms
of what we just saw it was like I like
a platforming and just kind of mild
exploration no real combat definitely
know like we didn't pilot anything so
it's a shame that we didn't see more but
it was interesting that we got a good
look at this particular environment what
did you guys think about the planet that
we were on I mean in reactions to that
specific environment I mean well the
first thing I noticed was that obviously
they're in a cave but it looked like
there was a lot of sort of alien
technology or alien structures
underneath them or something like that
they were jumping from the like platform
the platform which I thought was pretty
cool it shows an interesting design but
still I feel like a game like mass
effect that's about like exploring a
huge vast galaxy that was like you said
just a very very thin slice right thing
but like that wasn't on the top of my
list of things I want to see yeah but I
mean november seventh were supposedly
getting more so yeah that was
interesting that they teased a date for
when they're actually gonna show a
trailer it's like normally that's when
you would insert your release date but
they're like this is the date we're
gonna actually tell yourself about a
game I mean you know since e3 people
been just dying to see what this game
was and now you got something that
wasn't off-screen gameplay of a Mako you
know moving around what I will say what
I having to rewatch it again was don't
you the ending of the cutscene the show
being they like you know some ancient
alien technology somehow they interact
with and off you caught that but
whenever I see red in that game I think
of like the reaper beams and stuff not
only that you see this beam something's
going wrong some something's is hacking
them right I think it's like another
form of the Reaper you you even get like
the sound effects that really heavy
distorted like war cry they have the
actual Reaper you know walkers it seemed
like maybe it's it's a second coming or
the me know yeah I'm you know assuming
or you know how about hypothesizing by
like right it almost felt like an
ancient Reaper you know seeping out of
like whatever planet there you know
exploring I mean you may not be too far
off the Reapers are obviously like the
sort of iconic trademark enemy of the
series and you know supposedly that
third has been dealt with and this game
takes place like a thousand years after
the conclusion of the original trilogy
so but then again this is like a long
ongoing threat within that universe so
it's entirely possible we'll see them
return in some form who knows I mean
unfortunately even though we did get to
see the game in action
plenty of still unanswered questions so
yeah I guess we're just gonna have to
wait for november seventh roll around
when will finally get more so yeah you
guys have to want to stay tuned come
back to the site on november seventh
when we will break down some more
footage and hopefully get into some of
the gameplay an exploration of Mass
Effect Andromeda currently scheduled to
come out a q1 next year what do you guys
think it's gonna get the late again do
you think it's gonna hit that window you
guys are not i'm gonna get delayed yeah
i mean given that we're seeing we've
seen so little so far and we're just
getting this little trickle now here in
September like within six months when
the game is supposed to launch not a
great sign although personally I'm okay
with getting pushed if it needs that
time I mean if it means we're gonna get
a better game then that's okay yeah I
feel exactly the same way I want I want
this game to be good as I'm sure many of
the fans doing the developers do so if
they have to delay it that's fine i
think it's gonna sting a lot though
because there's been lots of delays for
this game already yeah r to one or two I
think too I think to officially and
there was a long period of time and we
didn't have any kind of indication when
it was coming out but now for now q1
next year and if nothing else stay tuned
to gamespot com for more information on
Mass Effect Andromeda as it becomes
available we'll see you later